здравствуйте 1
[музыка]
здравствуйте анна здравствуйте стиль
сегодня я буду говорить по русский
я буду говорить за мной чем черная да и
преподаю и я для меня сложно говорить
по-русски потому что я занимаюсь другими
языками
но увидев она у меня есть много вопросов
ну я хочу во первых вам спросить делать
представляет представляете себе
пожалуйста когда где вы живете
когда это случилось что вы
преподавать русский язык через я живу в
нью йорке я живу здесь уже практически
10 лет и я начала преподавать русский
как только приехала сюда в россии я
окончила лингвистический университет то
есть я профессиональный преподаватель но
когда я приехала в нью-йорк я подумала
что мой английский наверное никому здесь
не нужен а я преподаватель английского
языка по диплому и я решила что буду
преподавать свой родной язык и оказалось
что у меня это неплохо получается и
постепенно я развивалась развивалась
потом начала снимать видео на youtube и
вот сейчас я преподаю пишу курсе я и
делаю видео 3
у меня вопрос первых дужки русский язык
это очень огромный язык
в точки зрения литературе с точки зрения
самой россия это огромная
огромная страна огромная история и для
меня это очень привлекательны но я
людей которые с вами учат русский языки
как как я их мотивации знаете основном
из моей практики в основном это семья
то есть в нью-йорке очень большая
русская община
а и у многих моих студентов или русская
супруга или русский супруг а или
они хотят чтобы их дети говорили
по-русски да то есть иногда это русские
родители чьи дети родились в америке и
они хотят сохранить их язык а потом
конечно же тоже есть люди которые любят
русскую культуру русскую литературу но я
честно говоря думаю что это очень такая
объемная цель когда мне говорят что я
хочу читать толстого и достоевского
по-русски это конечно требует огромного
количества усилия и многих-многих лет
работы
а ну и третье это наверное бизнес то то
есть люди ведут бизнес россии и поэтому
им нужно изучать русский язык
думать ли вы что в сравнении с другими
языками русский языки это сложно а вы
знаете все зависит конечно от того какой
ваш родной язык но если мы говорим о
людях чей родной язык английский до
русский трудный язык потому что в
русском есть грамматические концепты
которых в английском нет это подержи это
глаголы движения это вид глагола да и
конечно же алфавит он совсем другой
и слова они не звучат похоже на
английские слова так что да я считаю что
русский объективно трудный язык это
интересно для меня сложность
языка это нет не самой важной
мотивации самое важное и сложность языка
например русски в случае русский
русского языка
буквы это это не очень трудно если
сравнивать арабский или китайский
грамматика да но есть концепция в
русского языка которые не существует
по-английски и
или то же самое с этим немецкого языка
или что угодно для этого я я думаю что
самой важной это все равно это это
мотивации случаем ваши и студентов те
люди которые изучают русский язык потому
что у друга ли мы говорить по-русски или
или опять отец мы жили что-то и эти люди
мотивации этих людей если сравнивать
людей с людьми которые изучает руки язык
потому что это интересно потому что
истории культура все этого интересно из
этой две группы кто бы мотивировало
мотивировали на ваш
и опыт прекрасный вокал стив вы знаете
если я об этом буду думать наверное я
скажу что те кого интересует культура
потому что те у кого допустим русская
жена ли русским уж рано или поздно они
могут бросить изучения потому что но
сложно нет времени есть семья есть
другие заботы а если человек влюблен в
культуру то конечно это его продержится
гораздо дольше поможет ему оставаться на
плаву гораздо дольше так что я соглашусь
с вами что нужно иметь интерес когда
изучаешь язык а и наверно если ты
влюблён и
до в культуру из тебя интересует история
литература то это очень большой плюс
очень помогает да я тоже так думаю я
думаю что если кого то есть муж или жена
соседа
он или она будет края хотелось зачать
русский язык
но если нет мотивация это нибудь
отражаться на несколько месяц это сложно
сложно играть я хочу
сложно съесть до этого надо иметь
мотивацией да но если я я хочу вам
показать май и мою историю
русском языке на лейке
потому что я хочу связать vasya
5ok сау гнать все и выкинут из
я
техники немножко и оставить до этого
иногда не очень screen
[музыка]
ok
вы видите руки но если я там это
статистики в ли да это значит что
согласно статистике линьки я знаю
пассивно но я знаю 9 90 90 тысяч слов
по-русски конечно
слов слова словами это 3 слов окей я
выйти слать на систем невозможно в
каждом из 37
языки китай у нас есть не можем числить
до земли
нет невозможно но это это может 43
но всё равно я много
и как-то я читаю книги
но книги или титул всегда есть рабов
который я не знаю но всегда есть
но журналы или новости я все то я начну
много лет тому назад
это 14 лет 13 гибель периоды
каролина это городе а в руэде это
который
сколько я читал и я чето
313 белье на миллион 120 тысяч меня это
больше чем это не это не но я думаю это
больше потому-то я не все они только
тоже поэтому но очень долго я очень не
очень много
занимал и когда она у меня были деле
ясная побачите то но это все равно это
14 лет то значит это стал часто моей
жизни это стал сейчас мой жизни это стал
это представляет возможности как только
я хочу читать по-русски или смотреть
фильм я это могу сделать и русский мир
русскими в смысле
культура смысле человек смысле все этого
это очень очень огромный огромный мир ли
это это
да или это до меня много-много качество
много
кокетка зову довольство поэтому я
благодарен русский русский нации
хочет я думаю что для меня это самой
важной чтобы люди мог орудие все перед
arkham более все прибыли прыгать
преодолевать сложности ского языка надо
иметь всегда это это это мотивация
например я нет я хотел сказать что я вам
благодарна за то что вы вот таким
является
являетесь пропагандистом что или
русского языка в частности да потому что
я всегда говорю студентам что
русски это огромный мир и если вы
потерпите и преодолеете действительно
трудности которую вы встречаетесь с все
едино путь это награда будет огромной и
вам откроется целая планета то есть
русская культура невероятно глубокая
невероятно красивая и она стоит того
чтобы потратить
усилия и время на ее изучение на
изучение языка
[музыка]